[Music]
operation Abilene was one of the
bloodiest battles of the Vietnam War an
entire company nearly wiped out right
from miracle
his name is pitch it's save lives we put
him up for the Medal of Honor but he
never got the Medal justice delayed is
justice denied the Medal of Honor is the
highest recognition of military valor if
there is you'll prepare a full
decorations review mr. Fitz and Barger
sir I've run the Department of Defense
I'm here to learn about your son if you
want the real story you'll need to talk
to the mud soldiers I've never seen
awesome men like that his some bum comes
down that why I say he's mad he never
even knew it sounds like a suicide
mission
suicide is hopeless Lucas embargo did
was valor he kept telling him to get out
but he wouldn't go
it was our save lives and that's what he
was doing why are you here because
you're here and we shouldn't even have
been there don't ever show what are you
saying that's friendly fire
we were fighting our own man
after-action report is missing we even
thought of operation a plan in the first
place it's not a can of worms you won't
open
why not information was removed from the
original review
in idea of your starting I have never
seen you back off of anything usually
we're judged by what we do but what we
don't do is what haunts us I'm gonna go
public with the story sounds a little
dangerous but only great television
didn't have metal 4 pits for me and our
loss might be the only decent thing I
pull out of that wolf but some are his
father it's time dying isn't harder than
losing our child do what you can
guys like pittsenbarger to what they do
for each other
life or a life I need to finish this
[Music]
can praise this young man assures that
the sacrifices of the fallen will never
be forgotten
[Music]